welcome back to the David Pakman show
i'm Ferren cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today so
there's been a lot of recent polls this
week coming out of the state of Texas
some show Ted Cruz leading by as much as
nine points we got from a the latest
Quinnipiac poll
then we had polls out today showing
better o'rourke leading by two points so
at this point you know probably closer
to a statistical dead heat
technically Cruz obviously probably has
a bit of an edge there but still neck
and neck for all practical purposes down
there in this very important Senate race
but here's the thing as those polls have
tightened over the last few weeks Ted
Cruz's attacks on his opponent have
grown from just the standard this guy's
bad to the absolute absurd this past
weekend at an event Ted Cruz allegedly
jokingly told the audience because there
were some PETA protesters there that if
elected Beto
O'Rourke could ban barbecue from the
state of Texas now all of the Ted Cruz
defenders immediately came out and said
listen obviously this guy was joking I
mean Ted Cruz is quite the jokester okay
but then why did he say it two more
times on different venues and outlets
because that's what happened after that
Ted Cruz said it at least two more times
that Beto will ban barbecue from the
state of tech if it was a joke you don't
go out there and repeat it if you think
it's something that's gonna resonate
with your base whether or not it's true
you do go out there and repeat it and
that's what happened with Ted Cruz he
saw that it hit and he decided you know
what I'm gonna run with this I'm gonna
keep saying it is if I say it enough
maybe I can
break ahead in all the polls maybe I can
just beat this challenger for good we've
had a tax from Cruz trying to say that
Beto is going to California our Texas
California our Texas that's something
that Ted Cruz actually tweeted out
earlier this week
don't California our Texas as if
California is just this land of Eden ISM
and horribleness you know despite the
fact that they actually have a pretty
pretty decent economy out there they're
moving forward on renewable energy but
yeah don't do that
Texas apparently because that means
bringing in tofu and dyed hair is what
Cruz warned people about I'm gonna bring
dyed hair to the state of Texas because
apparently based on Cruz's statement up
till this point
you couldn't dye your hair in Texas
there was no hair dye Peto a wark
is the guy who's gonna bring in the hair
dye for the state of Texas according to
Ted Cruz Cruz has gone after him for
being a former member of a punk rock
band as if that's something to be
ashamed of you know you really want to
resonate with the younger voters go
after music that's a smart idea saying
look how awesome this guy was he was in
a band
ooh right yeah probably not gonna work
out so well at the polls with the
younger crowd nonetheless it's what Ted
Cruz has done but I think personally the
most disgusting thing that Ted Cruz is
done during his race against Beto award
is begging Donald Trump to come to Texas
to hold a rally to help save him the
reason that's so disgusting one we've
seen the Trump rallies they're not about
the candidate at all they're about him
and Texas is probably a place that's
gonna play pretty well you sit there
brag about yourself for an hour
everybody loves it you talk about how
you hate those people coming across the
border they love it but let's not forget
what Donald Trump did to Ted Cruz during
the presidential campaign I
Donald Trump not only insulted Ted Cruz
personally he insulted his wife's
appearance and he also gave credence to
the conspiracy theory that had Cruz's
father was involved in the JFK
assassination Donald Donald Trump helped
kind of push that and now Ted Cruz in
spite of the fact that the man has
insulted every branch of his family tree
still says please come and help me and
save me from Beto
if I were living in the state of Texas
and I was an independent voter and I saw
that and I saw that this man valued that
Senate seat more than he values his own
wife his father any member of his family
that would immediately be disqualifying
for me I wouldn't tolerate it I wouldn't
accept it I wouldn't condone it and I
sure as heck wouldn't vote for it and I
think that's what the voters in the
state of Texas need to understand
sometimes you go past the policy
sometimes you do look at just the
personal character of someone and if Ted
Cruz values that little Senate seat so
much more than he values his own wife
to ask the man who attacked her to come
and campaign for him then yeah that
should be disqualifying another attack
that Cruz is levied on Beto and I love
talking about this because Cruz is such
a disgusting character is the fact that
he's mocking federal war for going by
Beto instead of Robert because according
to Cruz he's just trying to appeal to
the Latino community
Hispanics immigrants by changed his name
to Beto
really Rafael that's where you want to
be you want to be talking about people
changing their name mr. Rafael Cruz I
don't think that's exactly where you
should be going with your line of
attacks Ted Cruz is in trouble he knows
he's in trouble but more importantly
other Republicans in the country know
that he's in trouble last week Mick
Mulvaney from the cfpv gave a speech
New York where he said Ted Cruz is
likely going to lose in Texas but it's
okay because we're probably gonna pick
up that Senate seat down in Florida with
Rick Scott running against Bill Nelson
but he said Cruz is probably gonna lose
because he's so the bull now mo vanie
actually said this to a group of
Republican donors gathered in New York
that Cruz is so unlikable and he's right
we actually know that from the time that
Ted Cruz worked on george w bush's 2000
campaign because he wasn't offered a job
within the administration after the
victory because nobody there liked him
when everyone that's ever spent time
with the man comes forward and says wow
i really dislike him maybe that should
tell the voters something you only know
the man from afar you only see him on TV
you see him at a campaign spot you don't
have to deal with him one-on-one but
just take the word of the people who
have had to do that even those who agree
with him on everything they still say
that he is an unlikable creep which
probably should give you enough to know
when you go to the polls and cast your
ballot you want to vote for the guy who
actually wants to do something about the
state of Texas better or Roarke wants to
make things better or do you want to
vote for the guy that even his closest
friends say is just really really
unlikable